i'm thinking of ending things from
charlie kaufman the writer of eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind and being
john malkovich
is an extremely complex deep dive
exploring love
regret and loneliness in this video
we'll break down exactly what was going
on
and provide further insight into the
film and if we have time maybe even
explain why jake's father hates billy
crystal
billy crystal is a nancy but before we
get started make sure to like and
subscribe if you like deep dives of film
and television it wouldn't be an ending
explained if we didn't start right at
the end
this is the final shot of the film a car
covered in snow outside a high school
but to figure out who's inside and how
it got there we have to go to the
beginning where we're introduced to a
young couple jake and lucy well at least
we think her name is lucy throughout the
film she's referred to as
louisa lucia and even ames that's
because she
doesn't exist she is merely a figment of
jake's imagination
of an idealized woman with no name that
merely exists in his mind when they're
on their way to visit jake's parents he
talks about his favorite poet william
wordsworth who wrote poems to a young
woman named lucy who he described as
beautiful and idealized as we'll see
throughout the film
jake takes bits and pieces of his life
and manifests them through this
character and
others here are a couple of examples
when lucy finds
jake's childhood room she sees a giant
book of wordsworth poems
a book by ava hd called rotten which
contains a poem that's heard throughout
the film called a bone dog but we'll get
into that in a bit there are books on
physics
ghoth's theory of colors i hope i'm
saying his name right and a plethora of
films we see lucy take on aspects of all
of these things when she recites bone
dog as her own poem
how she studies physics at university
her theories on how color is merely a
construct of our mind
and her insanely analytical dissection
of the film woman under the influence
which puts my analysis of films to shame
lucy is a woman who represents all the
things jake
never became for example lucy shows
jake's parents her paintings
these aren't actually her paintings
rather romanticist painter ralph albert
blakelocks she believes these paintings
are a reflection of her innermost
emotions but
jake's father brushes them off saying
how can a
picture of a field be sad without a sad
person looking sad in the field
we'll later find the same paintings lucy
had on her phone which are actually
blake locks
as inspiration for jake's paintings he
did as a child
now buried away in the basement to be
hidden away and never seen of again
perhaps that's why jake tells lucy he's
afraid of the basement
i hate the basement if you really want
to know
basements are scary the paintings are a
reminder of the life of an artist he
could have had but never followed now he
lives his life as a lowly janitor
jake is this janitor what we're seeing
throughout this film are the moments
right before his death
as he plays through his life of what was
and what could have been near the end of
the film we see him get into a car
and take off his clothes during this
freezing blizzard ironically moments
prior to this scene
lucy questioned how long it would take
for someone to die of hypothermia
perhaps even more sadly poetic is that
final shot of the car covered in snow
it's framed just like one of jake's
landscape paintings
according to jake's father these
paintings are devoid of emotion because
there's no person in it to tell us how
to feel
this final image although ambiguous i
would argue and
possibly kaufman ii is full of emotion
in fact it's one of the few shots in the
entire film that is bright and colorful
perhaps suggesting that jake passing on
into the blue where he can live forever
in this dream of his accomplishments is
something good we literally see him
accepting a nobel prize set against the
background of his favorite musical
oklahoma at his high school where his
peers once sneered at him
now cheering as the frame fades to a
bright blue
he is happy the janitor is a romantic
not in terms of the style of art he
likes but how he longs to be with
someone there's a great scene where he
watches a fake robert zemeckis film
called order up it's a romance in which
a man strikes up the courage to tell a
waitress he loves her
jake never was able to do this in real
life too shy or afraid
about halfway through the movie his
mother even says to lucy there's so
many many things that make him nervous
he keeps closing off
more and more of the world it's a
problem this nervousness forced him to
become
more introverted and keep to himself
there's a great line
early on in the film people stand on
healthy relationships because it's
easier
basic physics jake has stayed in an
unhealthy relationship with himself
one in which it's easier to live alone
than face the anxiety and nervousness of
putting himself
out there we're told that lucy is also a
waitress just like in that movie but we
learned that the story about how she met
jake at
trivia night never actually happened the
real story is that jake watched her
creepily from afar and never had the
courage to go up to her what we're
seeing here is his imagination of what
could have been if he had gone through
with it the janitor's life bleeds into
this younger jake's dreamlike world
for example the girls who snicker at him
in the hall are the girls who work at
tulsi town the loner girl with the rash
in the hallways also works there
these two dancers who are rehearsing for
oklahoma smash into the locker just like
jake's dancers do during their routine
and we should talk about
that lengthy interpretive dance near the
end it's essentially what his life could
have been if he had the courage to ask
that girl out it's
happy joyful whimsical that is until the
appearance of the janitor the
representation of jake's self-doubt his
real life
it crushes the dreams of what could have
been literally stabbing it to death
and all that's left is a sad janitor
having to clean up the mess
it's no surprise then that after this
scene is when he goes into the car
takes off his clothes and freezes to
death that's when we get this odd
transition where he follows an animated
pig into the school which i
interpret him as him finally passing on
so he can dream his perfect world where
everyone cheers him on as he accepts his
nobel prize
this isn't the first time pigs have been
brought up one says come join me on a
billboard for
tulsi town but the more important thing
here is jake's story about his father
and the pigs where the father forgot
about them only to find out maggots were
eating them alive
several days later the pig in this
metaphor is
jake eaten alive by life or perhaps the
life he never had his father had
forgotten him
just like the pigs when jake first
arrives at the house the father won't
even look at him it's almost as if
jake doesn't exist even the pig says to
the janitor
it's not bad once you stop feeling sorry
for yourself because you're just
pig this makes things all the more
creepy when you find out that they have
pig for dinner so after this pig's story
lucy says of animals and it's voiced
over an image of the lonely janitor i
might add
other animals live in the present
humans cannot so they invented hope
it's when jake lets go of this hope and
kills himself that he becomes
one of the pigs so the janitor follows
the pig to the high school stage where
we see
jake giving an acceptance speech for the
nobel prize everyone is there in old
person makeup as he sings
lonely room from rogers and
hammerstein's oklahoma the entire song
is about a judd who lives a pretty tough
life during the day but as soon as he
goes to bed he dreams look at an example
of some of these lyrics
and all the things that i wish for turn
out like i want to be
or and the girl i want ain't afraid of
my arms this song is about him and the
dream we've just spent two plus
hours watching jake works as a janitor
during the day just like
judd works as a farm hand but both men
at night are able to dream of a better
world we aren't given the full picture
of jake's
life just bits and pieces here and there
mostly through the lens of lucy there's
an interesting scene where lucy finds a
picture of her younger self on the wall
only for it to turn into a picture of
jake further hammering home the fact
these two are one and the same there are
at least
two scenes where we hear jake's parents
argue in the background
hinting that he didn't have the most
happy childhood his father didn't take
an interest in jake's work but his
mother did however we'll see how she
succumbs to alzheimer's and
jake has to care for her there's a
heartbreaking scene where lucy tries to
console jake who has decided to care for
her ailing mother instead of putting her
in an old folk's home which lucy refers
to as a warehouse
it's a thankless job one in which jake
says sometimes
it feels like no one sees
the good things you do not only is jake
a caretaker for his parents but his
literal job
is a caretaker he lives a thankless life
dreaming of one in which people
recognize him which makes it all the
more ironic that he accepts an award for
all his life's work at the end even if
it's all a dream the movie a woman under
the influence which lucy goes on a
two-minute tirade on
centers around a man having to care for
a woman who is slowly succumbing to
mental illness
you may have noticed the film is shot in
a narrow aspect ratio with these black
bars on either side
perhaps it's because we're only getting
glimpses into jake's mind
not the full picture or as the poem bone
dog puts it
just the bones everything you see now
all of it
it's as if she's saying this directly at
us what we're watching
are just the bones of jake's life even
jake says of the poem
it's like he wrote it about me his life
has been filled with things like the
labels found on his shelf
abandoned friendships futile efforts and
success and unforgettable mishaps
i couldn't help but feel sad at the end
but at the same time hopeful that he can
now
finally live the life he's always wanted
if you stay until the post credits the
frame lingers just like
jake did to lucy as we hear what appears
to be a snowplow
arriving to find what awaits thanks for
watching everyone this was definitely a
doozy to write so i'd appreciate all the
likes shares and subs plus
hearing your comments below i'd also
love it if you'd follow me on twitter at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much